welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this video were
breaking down the top 5 deleted scenes
in comic book movies that should have
made the final cut superhero movies are
often lengthy films since I sometimes
have to tell comprehensive origin
stories and dish out a decent proportion
of action on top of this they usually
have to create an avenue for future
films in the franchise all without
sacrificing the plot or making it too
oversaturated with redundancy as a
result of this during production Studios
usually leave a lot of scenes considered
to be irrelevant out of the final cut
these removed scenes are often smaller
character moments detailed exposition of
plot points or Easter Egg additions that
have been considered to affect the
progression of the movie you start to
wonder what might have been if the
studio's had just stuck to their
original script or retained and utilize
the deleted scenes and in the case of
movies like Batman V Superman we know
from the ultimate cut that these scenes
can make a big difference throughout
this video we're gonna be going through
some of the best moments that we think
should have been left in even though the
studio decided differently there may be
some spoilers here too the films on this
list so if you want fully up-to-date
with everything in the MCU or DC you
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into a
breakdown of cutscenes that should have
made well the cut okay so the story of
how Warner Bros meddled with the Suicide
Squad movie is now common knowledge to
everyone this interference was said to
have included extensive reshoots to
match the tone of its new comedic
marketing campaign
judging from the large number of tease
scenes in the trailers that didn't make
it to the final cut and reports by the
cast of such scenes there is no doubt
that the studio really altered the
production to arrive at the theatrical
version so although the movie did do
well commercially a lot of fans were
really disappointed when their
expectations were not met the greatest
of all these disappointments seemed to
have stemmed from the shortage of an
on-screen representation of Jared Leto
the maniacal Joker who was said to have
had just about eight minutes of screen
time in the final cut
this totally contrasted what fans had
expected based on the campaigns as they
had high hopes from
unusually method acted Clown Prince of
Crime
according to Jared Leto there are enough
cutscenes from the theatrical release to
make a whole Joker movie if this is true
then we can only imagine that the
reception of the film by the global
audience would have been a lot more
positive
many of the deleted scenes that featured
the Joker seemed to have shed more light
on the abusive and mentally disruptive
relationship between Holly and him her
gradual growth and fantabulous
emancipation were meant to be a more
important submarine self a sort of
antagonist in the movie in an earlier
curve the film Leto's version of the
Clown Prince of Crime was going to
accept the Enchantress his plans and run
off with Holly leaving The Suicide Squad
short of a teammate and vulnerable
however Holly soon realizes that the
Joker is just using her and she decides
to stick with the team to create her own
story furthermore it would have been
revealed that the Joker did not take
Holly's request for freedom well and he
would hold her at gunpoint this was
confirmed by David Ayer the director of
the movie who posted a shot from the
deleted scene and expressed his minor
dissatisfaction with the edits to the
movie that could have held an emotional
significance with Holly's journey to
self-actualization in addition to this
there were action figures that were
released showing a melding of the Joker
and Batman and though these didn't go
beyond some cool concept art and toys
it's a shame to think about what the
movie could have been had Warner Bros
not changed course
up next is infinity war and as it stands
it's one of the most successful movies
in the MCU for good reason the film is
filled to the brim with amazing
callbacks of moments and it's a stellar
example of a comic-book movie however
after the release many fans were
confused by the lack of Hulk in the film
as he'd appeared heavily in the
marketing similar to Batman Joker suit
there were also a lot of toys showing
the Hulk heroically busting out the
Hulkbuster this felt like the perfect
scene on paper but unfortunately it
never made it to the final cut thanks to
the infinity saga box set released
though we can now see how it was
actually meant to play out it's nowhere
near polished enough to get a final
release but there's a lot of cool things
in it the scene is banner pleading with
Hulk to come out and fight cull obsidian
but juxtaposing the theatrical release
Hulk actually does it
in doing so he forms smart Hulk it looks
like it would have been a great scene
but as we know in the end the Russos
decided not to go with it there was also
a scene in which Iron Man handed over
some armor to Doctor Strange and though
there are rumors that this could be
returning for in the multiverse of
madness it's crazy to think what we
could have had when the Avengers movie
released in 2012 it seemed like the
heroes were about to have their hands
full with Loki on the run and a deadly
weapon in his control in the theatrical
cut Nick Fury has to rush to assemble
them and when we're first introduced his
Steve Rogers in the film he's in the gym
all pumped up for his next mission but
if some of the modifications had not
been made to the final release things
would have turned out a lot different
this is because there's a sequence of
deleted scenes featuring Steve a man out
of his time doing his best to settle
into his new surroundings to do this he
watches old videos about the war checks
out files belonging to his old pals
visits New York and goes to a restaurant
where he meets a waitress that he later
saves in the final cut
perhaps the most awesome part of the
scenes that we never got to see was cap
getting love advice from Stan Lee
himself these scenes might have seemed a
little too slow for the fast pace
incurred by the crisis at hand but they
would have helped to show how Captain
America was dealing with his loneliness
before he had the Avengers also the Stan
Lee cameo would have gone down to be
another golden addition to the famous
list of cameos by Stan the man I can't
see why they cut this but I am a bit
gutted that we didn't get it in the
final release Henry Cavill solo Superman
movie Man of Steel brought a tone to the
Kryptonian story that was darker than
ever before yet it felt like something
was missing
it seemed as though the troubles of
raising a super baby had been largely
ignored in the movie whilst this may not
seem like much it would have been nice
to briefly witness and uncomfortable
encounter by the Kent's as a downside of
raising a child with incredible
abilities during an interview with
writer David Goya it was revealed that
such a scene was actually planned to be
included according to him there would
have been a moment where soon after
adopting the infant kal-el Martha and
Jonathan Kent took their new baby boy in
for a pediatric check-up the doctors
test clock's hearing with sound unaware
that with baby Clark's
hearing that this would make him really
uncomfortable the sound proves too
painfully assault the boys auditory
senses unlike any normal child
experiencing discomfort he reacts by
letting out a scream and this SH as the
windows this would have turned out to be
an oddly cute and comical moment but
according to the screenwriter cute and
funny didn't feel right as a follow-up
to the sequence containing the morbid
destruction of Krypton due to this the
scene had to be removed still we can
only wonder if this deleted scene would
have had any impact on the overall
reception of the movie seeing how many
criticize it for its diatone now before
we get into the rest of the video I just
want to let you know we're giving away a
free copy of the Skywalker saga box set
to one random subscriber all you have to
do to be in with a chance of winning is
like the video subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the list in
the comment section below the winners
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
April and the set will be shipped out
from then to ever get surprise so best
of luck to everyone who takes part and
finally when Thor flies into
supercharged vision with his hammer the
two almost have a fight but instead he's
thrown out of the window where he has a
brief moment of reflection and seemingly
comes to his senses
vision ends up apologizing for his
behavior and in doing so joins the
Avengers in their crusade against Ultron
however there's an entire fight sequence
missing where vision actually went head
to head with the Avengers following his
birth the character went up against Thor
Captain America and Iron Man showcasing
an array of his powers in a scene
included as a bonus in a blu-ray copy
inefficiently showcases the ability of
the sentient Android to hand a nice
beating to the core members of the team
were introduced to a series of visions
powers such as flight laser beams and a
temporal intangibility
also known as phasing while the scene
was replaced with a shorter substitute
where vision quickly comes to terms for
the civility it would have been useful
in showing the audience his skill set
from the get-go they would have
instantly known that he can fly phase
through solid objects via a powerful
laser beam and hold his own against the
might of Thor like it was nothing going
forward this was a scene that explained
why provision formed an armor which was
obviously in order to match Thor in
combat it's understandable that the
studio would remove such an epic scene
given the
fact that they had a screen budget to
comply with but it would have provided
the audience with a fast-paced fighting
experience whilst showing them our
vision and that's our entire list I hope
you had fun watching this and let me
know your favorite in the comments
section below
I just want to shout out movie flicks
plus who worked with us in creating the
list and script for this video and I
definitely recommend that you go and
check out that channel after this they
work with a ton of your favorite
youtubers not a great place for DC
Marvel movie news they've just dropped a
video on five reasons why iron man had
to die instead of Captain America so
definitely check it out after this if
you enjoyed this video and want to
support us from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep on a date with the channel
so hopefully we see over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this I've been definition you've been
the best I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you